libraries I think can have an amazing  role to play because they are like tanks  full of knowledge  so knowledge banks if you want and the  thing is though that libraries very  often tend to be sort of retroactive in  terms of looking back maybe one could  think of a library as about producing  the future maybe an archive of old stuff  it's not really about going back in time  maybe the archive is also about using it  about going into the future and then  that way a library could really be a  time machine through which we can look  into well what do we need to do about  changing things in the future and I  guess that also means so reconsidering  the you know the fact that libraries are  very often very stiff and inflexible and  you know they'll read to me really they  need to reconsider how to reach out to  people but clearly libraries are amazing  resourceful systems which we just need  to activate  you